foreign
comes from Thomas in Virginia I'm in the
early stages of becoming a first-time
homebuyer and I was wondering if taking
out two loans from separate entities as
possible for example if I'm buying a two
hundred thousand dollar house and a
family friend says they'll give me a
hundred thousand loan at a three percent
interest rate would I still be able to
qualify for an FHA loan on the other
hundred thousand from the bank if this
is possible how does this work
oof well aside from it being a bad idea
uh it may be possible we don't know a
lot of the details of this person's life
their income their debt to income ratio
but I would not be doing any of this
yeah number one we wouldn't do an FHA
we'd do a conventional loan because
they're cheaper uh interest rate and
fees uh number two I don't borrow money
from family friends because that's a
good way for them to no longer be a
family friend
um and so I wouldn't do that for that
reason let's say you were going to
execute It Anyway technically tactically
how do you do that well you have to
disclose the whole process to the lender
and so the lender has to understand that
you are borrowing money in addition to
the hundred thousand dollars you're
putting down as a down payment is not a
real down payment it's borrowed money as
well not disclosing that to the lender
that's making the first mortgage loan
um
is called fraud
criminal fraud because you induce them
to give you money without giving them
accurate information by lying to them
and so people do this stuff in real
estate business all the time and they
don't realize it's like go to jail do
not pass go and do not collect 200 stuff
now here's the problem okay
conventional loans only going to take a
first position meaning First Mortgage
position that means your family friend
is in second position
so let's say the world's worst
catastrophe happened
and
there was a car wreck and you were
unable to work
for for 10 years
and therefore you're unable to pay
either one of these mortgages
the first mortgage will foreclose
when they foreclose the second mortgage
holder your family friend
to protect their one hundred thousand
dollar loan they have to write another
100 000 check and buy out the
foreclosure
otherwise when the first mortgage
forecloses they lose their position in
the house
it wipes it out all mortgages behind the
first mortgage are behind the mortgage
foreclosing if it's a second mortgage
and there's a third mortgage or wiped
out
by the by the previous mortgage
foreclosing and so the only way for him
to protect himself is to come out of
pocket again for some more money well
that'll never happen you're talking to
people who've done this for 30 years it
happens all the time
you're talking to cancer doctors we know
what causes cancer okay and we know what
causes stupid and this is stupid
you're gonna get yourself in a pinch
you're gonna get your family friend in
the pinch unforeseen things are going to
happen things you don't think are going
to happen are going to come up he's
going to get in a problem and need his
money and come knocking on your door and
want his money right now something's
going to come up and you're going to be
a caller on the show looking like you
did something doofus because you did
something doofus don't do this was I
unclear pretty clear to me Dave okay
clear as mud didn't want to be unclear
but that is a scary situation it sounds
like you're not ready to be a home buyer
and that's okay but or you're trying
you're just trying to get a lower
interest rate because the guy's trying
to get three percent on his money
and the guy Mike and the loan and he's
trying to get a lower interest rate on
his mortgage and both of those are good
motivations but what neither one of them
thought through is all your worst case
scenarios and you know the only time
debt works is when debt works
and all the rest of the time when
everything works perfect it works but
all the rest of time which is all the
time that no it doesn't work it always
ends up coming back and biting in your
head and on paper you go this is an
amazing plan I'm a genius yeah you get
bit in your assumptions is what happens
and you know when you get bitten the
assumptions it hurts it hurts it leaves
a mark